and of course the pandemic has slammed
the restaurant industry
forcing many to permanently close and in
some areas across the country
new restrictions are making it even
harder for them to survive
let's bring in robert st john now he's
the founding member of the independent
restaurant coalition
he also owned several restaurants and
has been in the business for nearly
four decades robert just jumping right
in and getting right to the point
how difficult is it well uh
first let me say happy thanksgiving
arthelene thanks for having me on
and and i want to in this season of
gratitude and thanks i want to tell you
thanks for what you've done your family
what they have meant your your late
father his brothers and all your cousins
what they've meant to the music industry
in new orleans it's things like that
that have helped us get through
these times but you know the restaurant
industry is in crisis right now
no other industry has been hit as hard
as the restaurant industry has been hit
you know there are
11 million independent restaurants
across the country
500 000 restaurants 11 million employees
and then another 500 000 employees uh
that include like fishermen farmers
other ancillary jobs in the restaurant
business so
it's it's devastating right now it
really is what would you like to say to
congress
well what i want to tell you is that my
home side i'm in hattiesburg mississippi
my home state senator senator wicker has
introduced
a bill it's called the restaurants act
it's it's sitting in the senate right
now
it has bipartisan support we've got
senator graham senator cornyn
gardner tillis are on there on the
democrat side we've got senator schumer
kamala harris senator warren all of
those people if cosine we have about
half of the senate have signed the
restaurants act
it will save the restaurant industry it
needs to be passed in this lame duck
session because
here's the thing ppp was was good
but only eight percent of the ppp went
to restaurants and bars
and and we account for 25 of the
nation's jobs
uh ppp was a 24-week fix to what is an
18-month problem and what's happened is
everybody's ppp has run out
and restaurants are closing right and
left and now you've got weather coming
in i've got friends out in l.a
and chicago and new york some of my
friends in colorado who are doing great
with outdoor dining in the summer it's
snow in there now so that's over
yeah yeah so and their restrictions in
la uh
there for 10 p.m the restaurants have to
close the ones who
were able to open uh at all i want to
jump in only because i heard you loud
and clear robert that you want congress
to pass something during the lame duck
session
if possible and what i want to do right
now is mention your website i understand
your website is save restaurants.com
and i believe that viewers can go there
and kind of weigh in and almost speak
directly to congress through this site
to let them know that they stand with
you
and something needs to get done and
something needs to get done now
yes yes absolutely so save
restaurants.com
the house has already passed the bill
it's in the senate it has bipartisan
support
we can get this done you can save
restaurants so winter is coming and
winter is here
for the restaurant business and it's
going to be rough
you know we employ over 1 million single
moms
uh 60 of our chefs come from
marginalized community i grew up with a
single bomb
uh something's got to be done now we're
talking about 11 million workers
in america and 2.4
unemployment can be can be improved
right now tomorrow
yeah robert st john i'm sorry to cut you
off because i have to go they're telling
me but i want to tell you thank you for
the kind words you said about my family
uncle aaron is actually watching so he
heard you and thank you
for all that you do and happy
thanksgiving to you thank you take care
happy thanksgiving